we've just got another bit of breaking
news to bring you this is relating to
the double child killer Colin Pitchfork
he is the man who's jailed for raping
and strangling two 15 year old girls in
1983 and 1986 Linda Mann and Dawn
Ashworth in leicestershire he can now be
released from prison subject to
conditions this is according to the
parole board there has been a great deal
of public interest in whether or not he
should be released from prison but the
parole board have decided that uh
despite raping and strangling two 15
year olds in the 80s he may now be
released from prison we'll get more
reaction to that I am sure later in the
day here on Sky